unfortunately somehow we have this like
[ __ ] like [ __ ] mansion in l.a and
this is this is like on tv we've only
got one tv and no curtains beautiful
place so you guys picked a nice place
you guys want to like
stay in comfort yeah yeah
who doesn't want to stay in here uber
was driving and like the neighborhoods
were getting nicer
every uber driver that's dropped me off
he was like what are you what are you
doing
where are we like
it's really nice but then i feel the
obligation to like have to tip way more
than normal because they're like they're
like oh what do you do and i'm like no
i'm not there oh
he says i'm a youtuber no do you tell
did you tell people that no no no but
this is how the conversation goes like
oh do you work i'm like no no no oh what
do you do i work from home oh what do
you do from home all i just like you
know make me videos oh like on youtube
leads up to that and i'm like i need to
just think of a different profession
every time i i was uh talking to an uber
driver he was kind of like a he seemed
like a really interesting dude yeah
quite a character i'd say and uh so i
just started asking him questions
because i really wanted to hear his
opinion on things and i he's from l.a of
course when you're a strange person i
feel like you're like born and raised
here i was like uh i should ask him a
few things first of all i was like do
you do you like l.a he's like [ __ ] no
i was like oh why'd you live here he's
like man i don't know i can't leave man
and i was like all right that's what
they all say yeah yeah yeah
everyone says he was like i want to move
to miami and become a youtuber oh i was
like i was like yeah man what kind of
videos did you make he's like just
writing chicks
i was like i was like what do you mean
like he's like he was like you know just
say how the how the girls are talk about
them yeah yeah you make a whole channel
about rating women just throwing women
your adventures with them
have you ever heard of the channel prank
invasion
he did the same thing i was like all
right i was like
where'd you even begin with this
i was like uh do you even think that
like la should have like more public
transport he's like [ __ ] no man
i was like what do you think it needs
he's like we need more e-scooters
okay like it's a great idea it's
fantastic those scooters are really fun
honestly honestly i think it [ __ ]
works in cities where it has an
infrastructure of cycling because i
recently went to belgium uh and like
going like using the e-scooters in
belgium was it it was one really really
fun and two really really [ __ ]
convenient as well right right like
because we we me and cindy got out of
our station and we tried to like find a
taxi and like the [ __ ] line for the
taxi was like a [ __ ] mile long i
swear to god because there were just not
enough roads and not enough taxis to
accommodate everyone right so we were
looking at what everyone was doing and
everyone was either cycling or just
e-scooting so that's so nice yeah i wish
la was more like friendly to like just
like e-scooters cycling yeah yeah yeah
trains buses like in general like that
we don't have to rely on cars so much
yeah it feels like if you don't have a
car now like you're [ __ ] yeah because
wasn't there this big craze of just
people trashing e-scooters here or just
like throwing them to the river
i mean they are like i think they're
still talking huh they're probably still
doing it they're not ugly yeah because
like i get it if you leave it on the
streets just in like you're just looking
at the pavement or
yeah yeah like in in brussels everyone
was leaving it where people parked their
bikes you know so you just go to like a
designated section americans to be that
considerate
lost
in san francisco they had like rental
like it's the same concept where you use
your phone to unlock but yeah they
unlocked mopeds
yeah it was sick
we just wrote mopeds around san
francisco you don't need a license to uh
drive a moped i don't know michael did
it for me
like if you unlock the back they came
with two helmets because they know
people would like to write oh that's
cool that's really [ __ ] convenient
because if i had like other options that
wasn't uber and lyft that's our public
transportation yeah he says it's really
hard to get we're in lyft yeah the
prices went up and like it was hard
getting worse yeah it's really expensive
like how do you get around normally yeah
if you don't leave my apartment
do you drive
no
can you drive
yeah do you have a left i mean i have a
car
in japan that that would be called a car
it would be called a paper license in
japan yeah but
i don't like driving i don't like
driving either especially like
especially like driving here it seems so
stressful yeah yeah and i'm like really
panicky i think i'm doing other people a
favor by not going on the road you're
welcome
i'm saving your world i'm saving your
life everyone seems like a really bad
driver here yeah there's a lot of road
rage stuff i just i don't trust myself
why do people just get super [ __ ]
angry and like like immediately of like
a mild inconvenience like someone will
like maybe because they don't want to be
here they're like
yeah because they don't want to be here
if that's the same people where you go
do you like la and they go [ __ ] no
honestly ella you just live here for
like um the people yeah yeah yeah yeah
voiceover is here too for me but it's
like yeah if i had to pick somewhere to
live it would not be
honestly like i get it because i would
not want to spend any more time on the
road in la than i need to yeah like
being in la traffic here i like i i
experienced it for the first time the
other day i'm like oh this is why every
la person complains about traffic it's
like you you're a piece of your soul
just like gets lost every time you get
stuck on the highway jacqueline knows
kiddos
i have some real depression in there
yeah it's yes 10 years on twitch
is it 10 years on twitch as well oh my
god yeah this this year well this month
or next month is my 10th partnered here
on twitch oh my
god like the livestream.com justin.tv
own.tv like i've dabbled in that before
wow you sound exhausted just saying this
yeah i could hear like a decade worth of
ptsd coming out a lot of like oh my god
can you there is
like 10 years worth of like imagine
being
little 19 year old lily
hi boys girl on internet the comments
you would get like when you just start
out when like it's not as common yeah
oh i need a therapy yeah
no good now i'm a well-functioning happy
healthy adult
how did you i mean get over it i guess
just gotta get what are you gonna do die
at this point it's like what other life
skills do i have you know let's be
honest he doesn't know my streamer i'm
straight off without like music full
time it's hard to make money off of
music full-time i'm learning i do make
like music yeah i upload them on
streaming services
but
it's like full time it's really hard
yeah yeah it's super hard yeah so i
think streaming and youtubing is a good
like way to supplement what you really
want to do yeah you know all the
producer costs or like yeah um voice
acting classes or stuff like that yeah i
mean you like you dabble in a lot of
things as we've established at the
beginning so i think that's a good kind
of lifestyle yeah i think it's very good
like i think i'm super privileged like
i'm very thankful i can do this because
you know it's like everyone wants to be
a streamer or like a content creator
and i did start when there were not many
yeah i think i did get lucky in that
sense like if if you do think if you
started now with absolutely nothing you
could make it oh god hell no i mean like
they think the bar of quality now is so
much higher so much higher you spend a
hundred thousand dollars on every video
yeah
with lighting it's insane like back then
i feel like it was so much easier
because you know more visibility less
saturation yeah but also i think you
know
when you're like let's say you come in
now now what you like your baseline of
what you expect and what you think and
how to make a video it's probably gonna
be better because everyone else is also
better i feel like back then everyone
was bad because there was no frame of
reference of what good it is yeah no one
knew what they were doing back then yeah
like equals three was the biggest
[ __ ] show on youtube yeah have you
tried watching equals three it sucks
[Music]
it didn't age well it is bad like and
that was that like the biggest thing on
youtube like that's weird but i remember
i used to watch that [ __ ] man yeah
i feel like the formula was there you
just removed all the commentary and then
now you have like daily dose of internet
yeah which is which is basically like
compilations oh just meme compilations
right you know it's i i feel like there
was something there with equals three
and then yeah but the bar always changes
right it always like someone brings
something or someone adds something like
you know like mr beast has like changed
how everyone makes youtube videos yeah
his style has made it like
youtube changed over like the past two
years more than i've ever seen it yeah
like ever definitely because this style
of now everyone talks at like 5 000
words per minute and screams and i still
have to watch it at 1.5 speed that's
that okay wow how do you watch that 1.5
speed so my problem is i like when i um
when i want to uh digest information i
prefer reading i read very fast yeah i
can like read really fast but when
they're talking you hate that it's
please
sometimes you just need to digest the
information you know it's like i'm
getting 1.5 and then yes and i have the
subtitle thingy on it's that that's what
i like oh jesus i guess you just like i
get it you're just like
like unbuffing yourself
just like you know what this is too easy
i'm gonna make it hard on myself
some people just speak too [ __ ] slow
man yeah some people those years of like
reading reddit you know paid off yeah
dude until i warned my friends if you
have chat loud open on your phone like
glance at it i will read it like i can't
help it so please
point it away
like a [ __ ] fiend for words you're
like i could reach you
i like readings
oh my god there was one time it was
really funny i told the story all right
we're in a car scar's in the front seat
right he's in a dm
with this girl right all right i'm gonna
make a name um give me a name
barbara okay she's in the ground with
this barbara and the reflection from his
stadium was in the car window i read
that and i'm like so who's barbara
escara and he was so shocked he's like
what's wrong well that's [ __ ] creepy
if i turn around and you're like
oh my god because it was far away but
then like the reflection from the front
window i could read everything i'm like
i'm just warning you like you know
i'm scared i'm scared to pull like my
credit card out in front of you now
she just scans it in you know i'm not
interested
i think chat logs and stuff like that
are most interesting because like i feel
like i learned a lot about people right
how you type when you think no one's
reading yeah
sorry that sounds really cool that's so
scary